Like one of the things that keeps Kanye West relevant is it?
He's constantly putting out music constantly puts out stuff that people love.
He constantly puts his stuff that smashes and some guys lose their enthusiasm
for productivity.
Yeah,
prefer being prolific.
They lose that and then they don't put out stuff anymore and then they become
like Rod Stewart,
like Rod Stewart.
I'd like to see Rod Stewart.
I'm a giant Rod Stewart Fan.
I like it when Maggie may comes on the radio.
I get excited.
I love that Goddamn Song.
I love a lot of his music.
He was,
but how many tickets we sell right now?
You know what I'm saying?
Will he sell out the staples center?
I don't think you will know.
You know,
you know when you,
I know you're still working on Kanye coming on the show and that's not even
though United okay.
Would if he wants to do it,
but I don't want to put any pressure on anybody.
Absolutely.
And I don't necessarily know that podcasts are the best place for someone,
for everybody.
They might not be the best place to just talk about shit.
But did you better just do music?
Did you get to talk to him at least on the phone or what?
Yeah,
yeah.
Very nice guy.
Let me tell you,
man,
he is so opposite his persona,
like on the outside like that you see in like in gossip magazines and on TV I
used to host has done to west foundation a event in Chicago and a lot of people
don't know the good he did in Chicago.
If they had perfect attendance,
he would go there every year,
throw a huge concert,
bringing like a common and all different types of Chicago artists.
He would,
uh,
bus everybody in from all over the city and throw a free concert for all these
kids that had a perfect attendance.
And it was good to interview him that way because he's at that time,
at that time when his mom was still alive,
he was such a down,
down to earth humble guy and actually shy and shy.
Like he was really shy,
still wet.
And this was at the time I would see stories about them yelling at sway,
you know?
Yeah.
And I'm like,
this is not the dude that I interviewed.
He's volatile and it goes all over the place.
Yeah.
That's part of why he's actually explosive artists.
Oh,
he's an incredible,
incredible guy.
Those are the people who think different and maybe that's stupid.
Apple ad think different.
Yeah.
There's people that really do think different differently.
That's one of the problems with that.
Apple had to English grammar,
but they,
there's people out there that just have a different vibe there.
They're on a different frequency.
There are different wave length and they're the ones who create great shit,
man.
He has a gift.
I mean,
he is,
you know,
a lot of people outside go,
oh,
he's out there.
He's definitely out there.
WHO's out there too.
Yeah.
But he's a genius.
He is a genius.
He's doing something in a different way and that's a,
that moves our cultural long.
That's what it's like.
That's what when you're doing stand up,
right?
Like if you're,
if you were nailing something,
if you really locked down something and boom,
you put out a live on the sunset strip or a delirious or something like that,
you're changing culture.
You're,
you're making people,
people are going to spread out in these ripples.
Yeah.
We're going to go to their job in the morning like we saw Michael,
Yo,
holy shit.
He does his joke about his cat and whatever the fuck it is,
wherever the choke is,
and people would be crying,
laughing and that there's ripples to that as positive ripples.
You change things.